well you know I was saying earlier this
morning that one of our producers raised
a very good question which is without
Jon Stewart why is anyone going to
bother watching Comedy Central what Jon
Stewart was much much more than than a
half hour of on-air talent as you
mentioned and Tom keen show Betty he he
was a focal point of a medley of
programming of very talented talking he
was a talent fine yeah and and colbert
came from him and and john oliver came
from him in a Comedy Central t the
entire value proposition today was that
was that talk peace late in the evening
and so when john leaves bad things begin
to happen the bundle concept is a larger
debate but the Viacom channels need to
get some resuscitation here they're
they're not is for those who don't know
the Viacom channels right so MTV which
by the way had been a crowning jewel
during the Jersey Shore days for m4
Viacom they were big a Nickelodeon but
then there's others like TV land's I
mean who watches that okay well the
folks at it direct TV not directv I'm
sorry Dish Network out in Denver have
suggested that they don't value the
Viacom bundle as highly as as they used
to and and there's quite a contra temp
now as to whether they wanted it all or
what they should pay for it you know the
way there's data backing that up there's
a there's a lot of data and so you know
the query here which is interesting is
is we know that Viacom sits alongside
CBS as a genuine sister same ownership
structure largely who needs each other
the most Viacom needs CBS more than CBS
needs Viacom and and the Stewart exit is
is a big part of that that you've
devalued at least for a while or about
to devalue the Comedy Central franchise
well you know reading through some of
these reports I mean it's so interesting
to see how actually powerful Jon Stewart
was to you know to a comedy central NJ
Viacom I mean 60 cable according to some
reports 60 cable operators
essentially have dropped the Viacom bond
a bundle in the last year or so simply
because they've seen struggling ratings
channels right uh they're also also talk
that you know cable operators would sort
of schedule their contract talks with
Viacom when Jon Stewart was on vacation
so they wouldn't have to worry about any
sort of blackout threats i mean you know
some of that maybe just hyperbole but i
think it just underscores how dangerous
it can be also to sort of pin your hopes
and your dependency on one person or one
brand you know les Moonves is a
programming genius some of that genius
is missing over on the biome side and
and to see them come together you're
going to have to see a resuscitation of
the creative side of Viacom to elevate
its value in such a way that CBS would
want it in the house well dome on is the
filament is the is the CEO of I yeah
come on I freaked on he's a former
attorney yeah my counsel to something
and very good very programming guy very
close to Sumner is his will be his run
his estate when mr. redstone passes
whenever that might be and I know he
said he's never passing remember that
yeah I said that once too had a few
spine surgeries to prove otherwise but
the no I think I think I said to you at
the break this is the most interesting
time in all the decades I've been in in
and around the media industry in it that
the premise for decades was that all
bows all boats rose on the rising tide
well now we're seeing some boats
actually sink when the tide rises and
others go up so that there's a lot of
contrarian outcomes here that my success
is now very obviously your failure in
certain aspects of the media industry
and so when when you get these hallmark
moments of Jon Stewart leaving that in
the old days would have been a moment in
time but now it's it's a perilous
perilous outcome for by up well its
perilous outcome for Viacom but I think
it also now calls into question even
more about this cable bundle right
it and whether that's going to be broken
eventually you know I think the bundle
will be broken but not in incident in
what might be to some an obvious way I
think the bundle is important it is
important that there be channels like
c-span and Nickelodeon and and Comedy
Central if it resuscitates and and in
channels that target ethnicity and
gender & faith and vocation and
application they just can't cost too
much and in the category that costs too
much is sports arts right the women are
men who are listening to us this morning
without knowing it without without
voting on it are paying monthly about
thirty to forty dollars a month for
embedded sports directly and indirectly
so it's not that Nickelodeon is
overpriced or Comedy Central's
overpriced it's there they're being
judged against the price of the bundle
exceeding the what the capability of the
audience okay so Comcast Time Warner why
don't you think that's why don't you
think that has gone through yet the well
the problem with Comcast Time Warner was
it's a very logical appropriate deal I
really believe that once it was
announced eight once that AT&T announced
that it also wanted direct TV at the
same time the challenge to the
Commission group grew greatly they had
to now assess to macro deals and on top
of that we then got dumped on net
neutrality as yet a third issue and i
still think Comcast Time Warner is very
appropriate and I'm having apparently
troubles with my mics here today a
Bloomberg the technology genius the and
it should go through it just taking a
long time it is and it got mired in in
net neutrality which it which is a shame
it should not have been and
appropriately it got mired in in the
duality of the AT&T your pro net
neutrality you know I actually thought
at one time I largely define net
neutrality and and as I define it I'm
very Pro and let me tell you what I
think that is I think it net neutrality
needs to mean three things
needs to mean that poor kids have as
much broadband capacity Betty as rich
kids that's vital it also should mean
that that people who provide broadband
services don't discriminate against
other people's content in favor of their
own if they own some and thirdly it
should mean that bandwidth hogs I should
pay the price to think that that somehow
extrapolates in the president's mind
making broadband a public utility simply
absurd I mean you can't make that
connection well there isn't a country in
the world no matter its form of
government who agrees with our president
on this issue that you know I came down
a public utility this morning called
Lexington Avenue and filling them as
pothole you know it could have killed me
and you know broadband is the future of
our economy it's the future of our
education system it's the future of our
entertainment networks and to think that
it belongs as a public utility is just
crazy regulator than that yeah where
have we seen that work anywhere else i
get i get no one I don't worry